well this you have to see Herschel
Walker did what was probably not a good
idea he held a press conference to talk
about this Scandal that has surfaced as
he is Accused by one of the mothers of
one of his children of urging her and
subsequently paying for her to get an
abortion despite claiming to be
completely against abortion claiming
that abortion is murder claiming that he
is against any exceptions for abortion
Health life of the mother or incest rape
all these different things and this one
was essentially an abortion of
convenience according to the mother who
said he said it wasn't the right time
for him to be having a baby he decided
to hold a press conference and I have to
tell you this is the most disastrous
press conference I can remember this is
as bad as any Trump press conference and
I remember when Trump talked about
injecting bleach okay
Herschel Walker can barely speak and so
when you put him in front of reporters
who are going to ask questions it's
bound to be a disaster and it was
I I don't even know where to start
Herschel Walker was asked
have you now that it has been identified
that the woman making the claim about
the abortion is one of the mothers of
your children
that's a known number of people have you
reached out to one of the mothers to ask
them hey are you the one and he says no
and the explanation is uh seems like
something out of a Dr Seuss novel
any of the mothers of your children
no to ask what why not uh I'm glad I
need to well because according to the
article one of the woman who says that
you Paige for her to have an abortion is
also the mother of one of your children
it seems like that's that's an easy way
he calls out the article I have more
kids okay he says because of the article
I had more kids
what does that mean I don't know an
article forced him to have a child
somewhere the article impregnated
someone with his DNA what does that mean
because of the article I had more kids
that's why I reached out to anyone
because I said no and that's what I mean
when I said no I said is not correct
that's a lie and that's what I mean
that's a lie
let me go to her thank you said that if
this did happen there's nothing to be
ashamed of how do you I never said you
said this morning you know what I said I
was talking about he did say that and
I'll have the clip so first of all he
he's told you said this morning in an
interview if this did happen it's
nothing to be ashamed of him he's like I
never said that he did and I'll play it
for you in a moment that's a totally
different
and what did happen I said but now it's
my ex-wife came in my past nothing to do
with what this woman said I said this
this year the abortion thing is false
it's a lot and that's what I said I said
anything happened with my ex-wife or
what Christian was talking about I don't
know okay so he said I didn't say that
thing this morning and yet here he is
saying that thing yesterday morning that
it would be nothing to be ashamed of if
it were true I'm saying I've been
forgiven because of all the things I did
when I went to my
and the thing with my ex-wife and all
that and things I did I don't know how
many years ago that I wrote in my book I
said guys I wasn't perfect
I had my problem with mental health
and I was uh I've uh I've been I I've
been I hate because I've been born again
but I have a new life and I've been
moving forward and and if that had
happened I would I would have said it
was nothing to be ashamed of that if
that had happened I would have said it
because it's nothing to be ashamed of
there he is himself saying the thing and
not exactly sounding like a guy
who has his story straight that's for
damn sure and this is one of the worst
candidates not just this election cycle
this is one of the worst Senate
candidates I have ever seen quite
frankly he should be dropping out of the
race but he might win I mean the voters
in Georgia
are coming up with so many post-hoc
rationalizations for this he might
actually win we'll take a look at what
polling looks like after the weekend
here's another moment from this
disastrous press conference he's told
hey the lieutenant governor said the
only reason you're even in this thing is
because people know you from football
and he's like what's the what's that guy
doing now and they're like well he's the
lieutenant governor and he doesn't seem
to get it
the lieutenant governor Jeff Duncan went
on TV I think last night and had some
very critical words of you saying that
the Republican party was in disarray I
think his directs both paraphrasing it
was the only reason he's a republican
nominee is because he scored a lot of
touchdowns for the University of Georgia
now who was it you said where did that
Jeff Duncan oh what is he doing now
[Laughter]
this is so insane what's that guy doing
it's the lieutenant government he's like
you know but what is he doing no what is
he doing are you adhesive he does work
for who don't go on some TV show no no
don't you go on the TV and talk a lot
no no they only go on TV and talk a lot
right now you know people like that do I
listen to you know people told me I
couldn't play football
listen that's true the lieutenant as far
as I know the lieutenant governor has
absolutely no no touchdowns to his name
that's uh that that's absolutely true
um
what's your reaction to people so close
to you saying you were dishonest like
his own son here's his answer to that
what's your reaction to people so close
to you your son a mother of your someone
who says it's you the mother of your
kids saying that you're lying once
you're actually people so close to you
saying don't trust you well just like
what I just said the Democrat is
desperate for this season the Democrats
oh God his son Christian Walker is a
devout Maga Republican this has nothing
to do with Democrats it's a I've never
seen anything like this who who advised
them to do this
they're very desperate for the seat I
love my family I always love my family
I'm going to win this race I know I'm
going to win this race dear God what an
absolute and total disaster
um I am hopeful that by Monday or
Tuesday whenever we get the latest
polling on this race I'm hopeful that
um this will be essentially over now if
we look at the polling again we're still
waiting on new data we only have two
polls right now that include any polling
after the start of this Scandal and most
of these polls were still before the
Scandal but it represents about a four
point swing in the direction of Raphael
Warnock as you can see sort of before
this entire thing Scandal uh the the
this this Scandal before the Scandal
started
um you had them roughly tied and Warnock
has jumped out to a roughly four point
lead and you see the the red line there
is Walker if you're looking along with
me Walkers polling declining 95 of the
polling here is before the Scandal so
Monday Tuesday after the long weekend
hopefully we will have some new data in
which it looks much much worse for
Herschel Walker and again in a normal
country in a normal planet in a normal
Universe a Galaxy whatever this guy
would have no shot but this is not a
normal situation when you're looking for
a good documentary to watch you scroll
through Netflix and Hulu for a while
there aren't that many you realize
you've seen the good ones what if I told
you there's a streaming platform
exclusively for documentaries with the
best selection where you won't run out
of top quality documentaries that is
curiosity stream with a massive catalog
of the newest and best documentaries
classic titles from years ago exclusive
content you can't find anywhere else I
just watched Pompeii disaster Street I
visited Pompeii in Italy before I wish I
had seen the documentary before visiting
because it was made very clear I missed
a lot when I actually went to Pompeii
you can watch curiosity stream on all of
your devices they're always adding new
titles politics philosophy True Crime
nature they have everything and my
audience gets curiosity stream for under
two bucks a month when you go to
curiositystream.com Pacman and use the
code Pacman the link is down below